des gars bien remplie pour un exode
massif conséquences des nouvelles
mesures sanitaires qui seront effectives
ce samedi soir pour quatre semaines
à la veille du week-end de pâques de
nombreux parisiens ont choisi de quitter
la capitale pour passer les prochains
jours dans une autre région
on a une maison un peu plus grande en
bretagne avec un jardin et que tel et
travailler avec mon petit garçon s'était
c'est compliqué donc donc moins là-bas
il à sa grand-mère sa marraine resté un
mois et demi de plus dans un appartement
de 30 mètres carrés est seul c'est pas
vraiment agréable socialement d'une part
et aussi parce que j'ai la chance de
pouvoir faire du télétravail
donc autant le faire là où j'ai des
espaces verts pour m'aérer un peu le
l'esprit pendant le mois qui va venir où
les deux mois qui vont venir mêmes
conséquences sur les routes où bison
futé prévoit une circulation classé
orange samedi et lundi
pour autant ces nombreux départs
laissent les commerçants sur leur faim
dans la station balnéaire de bandol dans
le var
la fermeture des établissements frustre
leurs propriétaires d'autant plus que
les touristes affluent dans la région
tous ceux qui veulent pas être confinés
chez eux qui vont descendre mais on est
fermée de soissons laon qui peuvent
descendre se balader sur le pas autant
qu'ils veulent puisqu'on a la liberté de
vous promener toute la journée ou à quoi
ça sert nous on est fermée donc qui
viennent nous qui n'aime pas les gens ça
ne change rien pour nous on espère qu'à
l'avenir ce qui a été promis va être
fait c'est à dire que là on nous a donné
de grands espoirs pour la réouverture
que tout le monde va réouvrir moi je
suis dans une une rue qui est
particulièrement vide quand les
restaurants sont fermés à partir de
samedi soir l'ensemble des français sera
confronté à des règles sanitaires
jusque là en vigueur dans 19
départements il ne sera possible de se
déplacer que dans un rayon de 10 km
autour de son domicile mais sans
limitation de temps le couvre-feu à 19h
reste maintenu les commerces non
essentiels devront fermer leurs portes
alors qu'une réouverture progressive des
lieux de culture des bars et restaurants
est prévue à partir de la mi mai du côté
de l'éducation écoles collèges et lycées
seront fermés lors des trois prochaines
semaines
si l'enseignement se fera à distance la
semaine prochaine les vacances de
printemps ont ensuite été unifiée sur
l'ensemble du territoire du 10 au 25
avril
cette fermeture des écoles intervient
alors que le nombre de classes fermées à
plus que tripler cette semaine passant
de 3250 6 à 11 1272 dans toute la france
falloir gérer j'ai prévenu mon
responsable déjà à mon travail
comme quoi j'allais devoir gérer
partager mon temps entre le travail et
les devoirs
je pense qu'au fur et à mesure des jours
de toute façon il y aurait eu beaucoup
plus d'écoles ou de classes de fermer
donc vaut mieux fermer
tout d'un coup enfin comme annoncé le
nombre de lits de réanimation dans les
hôpitaux publics sera porté de 7000 à 10
milles dans les prochains jours le
gouvernement souhaite également passé la
vitesse supérieure pour la vaccination
le groupama stadium stade de l'olympique
lyonnais servira de vaccinodromes ce
week-end ainsi que le week-end prochain
le stade de france se transformera en
centre de vaccination à partir de mardi
et au moins pour les six prochains mois
objectif injecter 10 mille doses chaque
semaine dans l'enceinte du plus grand
complexe sportif du pays